pour that wine river and we're about to
get a little tipsy
Cheers chicken Cheers - freshen - cheers
to that
cheers to us perfectly all right
question yes if I'm watching TV what am
I watching
you are either watching see often Bob's
Burgers freaks and geeks or at the
development
Touche other than that you're not liking
you because you hate TV - [ __ ] this is
where we are ready horror stories I'd
watch that a long time I haven't seen
the most recent like two seasons what do
you watch I mean every time I watch
something you're with me why does that
happen
because I don't like anything you want
you know Game of Thrones you watch Game
of Thrones yeah I need a man start just
say yeah yeah I can't watch TV with this
guy or anything that I like at all
because all you do is criticize it with
your movie I you just like all the right
act excitement don't even suck that
because of the writing better that I
think it's great actually I just I can't
relate to people that that's his number
one pet peeve with TV shows when they
act like that in which I don't mind and
I'm like cool as part of this TV show
genre like act like that all you want
it's all about like what the story
entails and the character development on
us so it is
and character development because no one
ever liked their stop London
I like the dweeby loser headache idiots
in the world because that's how I feel
in real life you know you're doing this
pathetic idiot when you put it that way
oh but everyone has a pathetic idiot
inside of them you know the version of
ourselves when we're outside looking in
or we just kind of feel like the
underdog I feel like I'm an underdog
99% of the time of my life yeah so
anytime I like a TV show I always have
to watch it alone
feel sorry for me guys are you putting
on watch never throws together
CSI whatever your one arm that might be
inside anyway next question is question
what is one food I don't like
so thought on that list I know it's
literally almost everything everything
that shiny food you don't like - maybe
beat middle Susan green onion pancake
you like love so do you really like an
order in Chinese cuisine yeah which is
the yeah I'm southern Chinese food
oh you don't like anything South Asian
actually but yeah these literally draw a
line in the middle of China and
everything Asian underneath that you
don't like is there any north of that
but you liked ringing through Japanese
through a Nigerian Chinese food man like
Mongolian sir I don't know if I had it
me neither
like like real modeling is good I don't
think I've ever had I've had two of them
on going in barbecue at the mall yeah I
don't think that's very accurate I put
the Panda Express them on going your
food I said sorry I don't know all right
so one food that you don't like
sandwiches
you don't like them it's just too simple
but to Queen and then the flavors are
very I think you just haven't had a
great knowledge to make a sandwich taste
good you either have to have Ruby
amazing meats in it which most of the
times I feel like places that you go to
get damages that don't necessarily to
meet and then you have to rely almost
entirely on the sauce we get some flavor
in it yeah I'm not big on sauce either
like if the food itself doesn't have
good flavor then there's no point in
putting more slots into it now you're
just eating it for the sauce might as
well just drink the sauce then right I
don't know just some bread in the sauce
that's a sandwich right there then I
don't know I'm not big on sandwiches I'm
weird
hi any questions what drinks do I order
when we go out to eat water thank you
new order water and if it's not water
it's some type of spear or or wine you
drink alcohol would be a pair of Silvo
of food that it tastes good
iein I sometimes like deep down inside
of me I'm like I hope he doesn't take
this lip as a hobby all the time
no he's good he only drinks whenever we
eat or in this particular case when
we're telling this video yes if u s--
what's the one drink that I ordered
right no no I think I order sprite maybe
like coke one cheaper sell coke coke
coke okay I'll give you a cup but I
would have said Arnold Palmer that you
can have one not even though yeah hey
order that means I've got dinner the
other night and I ordered all the
partner and then you order the beard yes
lemon cider oh yes I'm sorry sorry
anyways thanks I sent nice questions
what shoe size doing
I know you're a shoe size you don't know
I had no idea
good hey hey hey all to be precise
six-and-a-half but I can were sick
sometimes okay cool yes yeah yours is
mine enough sure I don't really know you
don't know your shoe size is enough yeah
I think so my own Xena's normal
everybody honestly every time I sherry I
always have to look inside like what it
was a lawyer just one number how do you
know open in a good computer like you're
saying like depending on the mega to do
it range from 9-10 you might be said the
business because it is from nine to ten
not a half is inbred sensor yeah this
next question swiping
was never established not looking at an
aftertaste though what was my favorite
sandwich bird if I'm eating healthy and
I choose to eat a sandwich
alright what would you order at Subway
yeah we have for example yes okay what
do you want to wait you always tell me
that order is amazing every single time
it can I look at my phone for your less
orders no because you always text me or
come I can't remember what is it um is
it roast beef is it is it roast beef ah
you got it - Joe what do I regret the
way Oh I'll be your announcer for speed
in the world I want to make a movie
Schroeder and that's how you know that
you want so many more each other because
I know you two years other boy you know
it's what we were it to way you order
this the same sandwich Isaac yes ham
sandwich black forest ham you do oh okay
that one got it right alright next
question next question what is one
talent that I have the talent that you
have that I feel like is like your you
know when talents become almost kinda
like it defines a person and you almost
look at them as if they're like a
superhero they're like super
like man how do you do that like how
does Michael Phelps swim that way or how
does LeBron James play basketball that
way like talent that makes you react
that way yeah what is it your interior
design / organizing skills like you are
like this this living room that we have
that's all you and then the way you're
able it great but thank you for - no I
mean you have this wave like knowing and
tough things away and I'm just like what
like how does your mind have a Tetris
codes unlocked and in your able
appliance in real life like that's how
your mind works don't like that doesn't
make any sense to me but that's awesome
you possessed that ability by just the
other day we're making for the way we're
making a Bruce board a collages for what
to wear for the wedding and my color I
guess - they've been asking us what are
we wearing your wedding more like well
we'll create something that kind of
helped you guys and then we had all
these images and tools from Pinterest
and online and I splash it on the canvas
being on Photoshop but then you know
there was like a lot of just edges that
there were they weren't all lined up
perfectly and I was like I don't know
how to do this because it's going to
take me like two days to figure all this
stuff out because three of them you know
one of the guys one for the girls and
one for the color palette and you came
in and like in two minutes we hash it
all out all three men was like perfectly
lined up and I'm like I know like put
that there make that bigger drag that
down move that over there
and he goes like how do you do this on
my own it's like in the video games you
know there's an character speaking in
slow motion that's my super down yeah
and every time we moved to all the boxes
are like aligned perfectly I don't know
I guess yeah cool habit Alan it's
organizing it's a crease Thomas oh
you're a talent is doing this thing that
you're doing right now future Casey
you're editing I really would say that
is definitely your superpower it seems
like I have the same reaction when I
watch it because I'm like I live that
but you make it look way more fun and
exciting and like you make me relive
everything in a way more like happier
light and I don't know really like
watching your work I always tell him I'm
like I'm
number one fan I love everything you've
done you have my number and how can I
remember back in the Facebook days
before we actually 90% I didn't have
that many people following me either and
like you know if you like my mom liking
stuff whatever but there was a lot of
personnel consistently liking everything
in it with you and it was not today
I was trying to tell you I really did
really love like all your projects I
really liked everything you did thank
you alright next question what would I
eat every day if I could
well I know what you have eaten before
that you don't like what is that that
you need in every single day which was
boiled chicken for us and broccoli grass
manager some sort of educator I know
brow right
yeah I'm brown right but what would you
eat every day because no you love too
many foods unless a Chinese does just
one which one which has I think it would
be in the Chinese food category but
which one dish I don't know I give you
hit pretty close to the healthy thing
new urges with Connecticut yeah and
chicken I could be hidin child I'll even
guess that what I wasn't sure that would
be answers I just went with I don't know
since up this is pretend to that was all
right actually said I can check it
correct what
no way how'd you guess that okay what
about we come and this is our and if
they were food with your so hard so I
don't even blame you because I don't
even know the answer
[Music]
thank you feel my saliva but he was like
traveling as breast I was about to say
something about it not that is I held it
as an excellent thing
well we really what is it I eat Taco
Bell every day's you could because it
all the food options that ever list out
on any given day so that we could eat
together and sharing meal together I get
rejections for just about everything I
list out except for one and that's Taco
Bell
you know I used to be Savoy and I'm
checking off but then chicken twins but
then every single week and there was
like a good chunk of time where every
Tuesday and every Thursday which are
shoot days to this party Thursday's news
every single shoot day we had Savoy
cater to us for lunch and I'm like oh my
god avoid out like it was too crazy but
before that I was like I can eat oh boy
every day but actually he's like once
they started doing that I was like I'm
out so I guess I can't eat Savoy every
day but Taco Bell every day I mean
they've changed their menu I am
Valentine's I probably could survive off
the Taco Bell every single day that's
disgusting yeah I love talking about all
right next question what is my favorite
cereal
their results roschmann you know yeah I
saw that one smells gonna be like
unanimous decision I thought that was
gonna be like then it was crunch done no
the reason why I hesitated because I
don't really have one favorite cereal I
love a lot of them like Applejack cocoa
puffs and toast crunch actually you
should be listening them what else who
else is like oh the toast crunch
Applejack what else you say your finger
on cereal you know a lot before I don't
like Google says allowing pebbles Google
puffs yeah you can cocoa puffs know they
want to hop you like pop pop no no I
only know based on what you actually eat
and you've gone through a similar
scrunch face you've gone through a pop
space a Applejack space
cocoa puffs a Google Pug soon I hope the
puns about it at that depth on the edge
because I bought cocoa puffs for the
cereal challenge that we did and we had
Stover and so you ended up eating it so
I did't know if you didn't actually have
to go out and buy it when you bought it
for the challenge I was like oh yeah I
forgot about this cereal I love this but
then at one day I got in it's like a
gigantic bowl because I was really
ambitious um how much see you should try
/ later Saturday morning card I was good
and then it was just too much I'm like
good I can't have cocoa puffs for a
while but your Garrett cereal a
sentimental attachment yes yeah if
you're not going to be healthy because
you all right I already died all these
cereals which I don't really even yeah
here I thought my favorite cereal which
I never eat but yet never touch my child
I am but Captain Crunch is as close
second though I forgot my balance that's
one of my compliments
okay the concho pickle you know what
we're we're cleansing pretty hard on
this cereal one I think we're just meant
to be you know we're like kind of soul
mate so I don't know he's okay but yeah
alright next question what is my
favorite Mutis mama's best musical we've
got me on that I say music in French I'm
French
there you go
that movie got moose big bad wolf
how about Cantonese I do it what no why
Thanks no I forgot cane goal hey I've
got listen to a song literally yeah mom
yeah are you in it yum-yum oh I don't
you know something oh right I mean
Cantonese a song I forgot I think I was
like 60% fluent and now I think I'm
dribbling down like 60% oh you got to
ammonium often again but your favorite
music I am going to say is um Paul
McCartney yeah for like just anything
seventies rocks area can you draw
anything and everything anything under
the
semi-truck yeah what about me oh my god
a really wide selection you do really
why
yeah on any given day though I think it
would have to be really kind of like
along the lines of Corvette that kind of
music whatever genre that is yeah I
don't even know what genre experimental
top slash it's not really pop is that I
ain't came to take office I have rental
no idea what genre that would even go
under sitting on like really chill kind
of like I like to listen to where the
music takes me kind of music nice
borderline trip-hop me like lounging
trip-hop I guess I would be more like
the Internet
Frank Ocean that's more me excellent
what is my favorite sports team none you
don't watch work yeah yeah good answer
e but let's just have fun what would be
my favorite soccer 14 soccer
you've never spoken about soccer ain't
no ever my eyes are kind of a friendship
what is it la wrong the only soccer team
I know is the Dallas burn oh yeah yeah I
don't you know they even existed I
growing up in the 90s that was it was
called a doper well I would have said
she that because my family's from was a
nut hat and that's the soccer team /
well they all have up last but I don't
like open it I'm getting drunk here for
that I can't finish answering my
question wait we're drinking more
knowing I think over all thirsty ha ha
okay what's your favorite sports team
yeah this yours would be um maverick
Dallas Mavericks that's your number one
we're seeing a cueing you get drunk very
nice question which way I closer
oh your eye color I see these brown your
throat too
that was a bushy yeah but as part of the
questions that we have in part of that
truth one who is my best friend gon tell
on net Quan yeah she's not bed that's a
you know it's okay what's your second
but webinars okay always my second but
better no I know I don't even know he's
your best friend
well I guess like your childhood best
friend Kevin but I guess who is your
best friend today Mike who's a person
you connect with the most I would say is
Michael yeah I see him the most often
and I had a ball to achieve the most
often I connect with in the moment
Michael gives our business manager
Esther is our business manager results
the business manager of JK many hat
he runs just about everything within the
j-team network he's without him
everything would fall flat and he's your
best bagger bad next question what is
something that you do that I wish that
you didn't do that's easy
you wish that I wouldn't lay in bed but
I can tell what I usually do is I love
relaxing in my bed I love my bed so much
that every morning I wake up and I give
myself about thirty minutes to an hour
and I'll just be on my phone answer
emails look for news articles for JK
news I work I work a lot on my phone and
I find it the most comfortable to work
when I'm laying in bed because that's
like my favorite thing to do I just like
reading of it and you hate it because it
makes you feel that I am NOT being
productive at all when I am actually we
just talked about this earlier today
deck this morning
okay what about me what is something
that you do that I wish you didn't do it
I figure what I do
hi-oh I recently bought some weight to
list at home because it takes too long
to go to bar Khobragade
to work out which is Bart's gym so I do
everything at home now which is nice and
close to this print you get at the gym
but anyway I like to lift weights at
home and when I lift weights at home I
ninety-nine percent of the time
fail to put it back where they're
supposed to be which is tucked away
neatly because you like to tuck away
everything neatly
but they have a place we have this bench
by the front door that people use when
they come in and out so they can take
their shoes off put them back on and you
love to leave the bench open with the
weights out right in front of it but
every time I pass by that area I always
like bump into it so I always tell my
toes when I don't notice that they're
there and I'm like oh I gotta put the
weights away I can't you put them away
like a tiny little annoying thing that
he does all the time where am I come on
just put them away but in the sense of
myself I would say it's a nice visual
reminder of myself that I need to work
out because I want to hide it then it's
out of sight out of mind and never touch
it again now and then now he's trying to
buy a punching bag that's like bigger
than the size of your body and I'm like
really really a punching bag
anytime you're answering away every time
I don't think that I gotta practice
punching things bigger than me
you don't need a punching yeah unless my
wine is coming up next question this is
bunch of funny push where am i from
easy does not get out lip gloss honk oh
yeah
and you're from Dallas yeah we take our
next one what kind of cake would you
bake me for my birthday
Sachin so easy questions are getting
easier and easier now that means we'll
get harder nard ah carrot cake yeah
carrot cake like old-people cake no one
likes carrot cake I'm the weird one
because I love the cheese the
cream-cheese frosting that's not very
hard
usually the carrot cakes I've had
they're always really moist all right
next question do I play any sports no
you know not you know you don't crazy no
do I think sports man you don't do
anything yeah that's for people we're
not we don't watch sports or others you
don't watch anymore and I never
sports I've never played in any force
ever in my life I used to play tennis
which I found really shocking I used to
play tennis I used to like playing
basketball did martial arts before but I
think as soon as I went to college I
think a lot cop collage I college
destroyed all my interest and
aspirations now but it paved the way for
everything else though you know it's
good thanks
what can I spend hours doing watching
movies true that's easy
easy everyone does that oh yeah there
really are particularly though I could
have to watch movies a little bit yeah
you know what I could do for hours
actually is have my computer editing
like whatever that is for hours and then
have a movie playing in the background
and I could do that for like 12 hours
straight and I just have like six movies
on and the Inuk you just go go go it's
then further proof mining and so yeah it
does it does really they're gonna be
sleep sleep Facebook's from your from
the bed laying down on your phone the
ground immediately changes answer when
one says asleep it's around from the bed
of another that's a key part to the
sleep / Instagram Facebook also in a bit
it's all from laying down in the bit I
can be in bed for like days straight and
then and then my heaven do you get
hungry you're like close facebook close
Instagram what's now mate
well hub postmates door - great every
single food delivery as possible it's
been my phone yeah I'm so lazy man it
come off like such a lovely person I'm
not leaving I yeah we're done I get
worked in am I really alive so she said
what do you feel I say
I still get work done alright last
question its I can live anywhere in the
entire world where would it be the hard
one there's an obvious answer in there
somewhere I think it applies to where
would you want to go where would you
want to visit that one I would say Bora
Bora
let's visit I've never visited that
place how am I going to want to live
that or something that people are crazy
because I'm pretty sure there's a lot of
people want to listen when they deliver
business well I guess this is going to
narrow down your question because I
would answer something that I've
actually visited Paris Terrace No
yeah we've answered Hawaii oh I would
totally look which part I love each one
of them have its own culture well I've
only visited a logo in Maui and I wasn't
a big fan of Maui so I would say well
but I kind of don't like how congested
it is either I probably would like a
North Shore something so for you or
would you want to live you're already
living here in LA I've already
transplanted myself over here I guess it
would be another answer why don't you
want to really visit this place better
enough this would be a place you'd want
to live never been dead before
no I'll do it no it's not for everyone
that's my Bora Bora but yeah I would
probably pick somewhere else it would be
some residences you would probably kick
ah I know it's nowhere in Asia right
really you can't Asia you're all about
Europe I love Europe in assigning your I
would consider living in Europe but
here's a good clue I was a pan no
however I would go somewhere that speaks
English so that would work I wouldn't
want to learn another life although it's
great to learn how language I don't want
to do is learning with it and having a
language barrier for me to the burger
yeah I knew that one
I've been there and I've actually really
enjoyed my time to sing aboard and I
took it in English and I'll get you to
live there yeah okay so you're here MLE
all right guys thank you so much for
watching this video
done yeah this boyfriend / fiance tag
yeah so great can't whisper emails okay
we drink uh we didn't really do at the
bottle not even half but it's still
pretty considerable amount
we're drink ing stomach so sorry it hits
up a lot faster I'm actually gonna but
but don't drop that was okay a mesh it
functions well what I was put the switch
and cooking shows I'm checking this sure
alright thank you guys for watching yeah
guys thank you so much for watching make
sure to give this video a big thumbs up
make sure to share this video with
anyone else that you might think that
they might find entertaining and we'll
see you guys in the next video bye hey
Lou toodaloo that's your ending I don't
know oh man wasn't going what okay
[Music]